ah the epic majesty of destiny how I
dream of fathoming it's unknowable
depths the sweeping vistas stir my heart
the sinister aliens chilled my soul the
powers of the guardians ignite my
courage and the sheer breadth of
weaponry well can any man even
comprehend how massive guardian blast
you dinklebot not now can't you tell I'm
setting a mood there are only nine
weapon types in destiny nine you say
well then hmm well then this is gonna be
easier than I thought
ladies and gentlemen hairdos and hair
don'ts welcome to the gun show the show
that knows no matter how far into the
mystical space future you travel there
will always be guns there might not be
like a lot of different guns or even any
particularly weird guns but by golly
they're there and where there's guns
there are tips strategies and other
brain upgrades that we're happy to pass
along regardless of your reputation
level it's come one come all in this
episode of the gun show
let's hit the ground running with the
four primary weapons starting with the
only primary weapon that you will ever
actually need the hand cannon if you
want to become legend as destiny urges
you to do the hand cannon is your map
compass and Boy Scout manual all packed
into one stone-cold sidearm just aim for
the head or the white Robo belly or
whatever glowing weak spots these
freakazoids show you and KaBlam aliens
start exploding like pinatas only
instead of scattering candy you're
releasing their eternal souls out
through their neck holds the hand cannon
makes you so badass that there is
literally no other option the grimoire
defines literally as in the literal
sense
shutup dinklebot god okay fine I mean
the hand cannon is awesome for PvE but
don't take it to the crucible unless
you're one of those GB teenage cyborgs
who don't know how to shoot anywhere but
the head with the speed of multiplayer
encounters and the hand cannons modest
fire rate you really can't afford to
miss because you'll just be Auto rifled
into oblivion so what's a robot lady
from beyond the moon to do get herself
an auto rifle and boom problem solved
well more like you problem solved the
fire rates on these things are some of
the highest in the game but beware of
going too high because then your recoil
will be too high and some of your
bullets will go too high and you'll get
killed by bong Ripken 240 who was too
high to even type a weed reference
correctly strike a good balance between
stability and fire rate aim down sights
to home in on the dome and you'll be out
audible Auto rifle errs in no time
as for Auto rifling aliens sure hey why
not works right it's good for farming a
guess honestly it just seems a little
gauche like shopping at Costco or
wearing the Jester Appaji Armour shader
I'm no fashionista myself having chosen
to wear this future war beach towel out
on the town but wouldn't it be classier
to roll with a precision weapon and
actually have to like aim enter the
scout rifle faster fire rate than the
hand cannon great for shutting down
vandal and Hobgoblin snipers without
expending
any of your precious sniper ammo real
talk it's just more satisfying to tear
your way through alien hordes with a
precision gun even if you're only
knocking out bounties that are beneath
your level
speaking of bounties the scout rifle is
probably your best bet for those
headshot bounties in the crucible what
with the range and fire rate and all and
a final bounty tip when you cash them in
be sure to have any weapons gear or
subclass that you want to level up
equipped because the XP bonus is applied
immediately hello
green circles with plus signs in them
all right there's one more primary
weapon to talk about and it's the pulse
rifle not as accurate as the Scout rifle
not as fast as the auto rifle it's the
worst of both worlds and only used by
dire chuckleheads alternatively it's
more precise than the auto rifle and
doesn't miss as easily as the Scout
rifle so it's the best of both worlds
and only savvy guardians of substance
use it okay the pulse rifle may be
divisive but it's just like the old song
goes I say tomato you say tomahto
tomatoes obviously right the pulse rifle
sucks dooby-dooby-doo Bop now if we
scroll on down to special weapon town we
find a trio of options awaiting us two
of them are sources of great pride for
the human race because in spite of
colonizing other planets and wielding
magical powers of strange origin we
still haven't managed to top the
boomstick and the long gun for killing
things that are really close and really
far away in destiny if an alien is
really close to you that means that a
it's pretty weak so you should just
shoot it with your primary or punch it
like a spaceup oboe or bee it's pretty
strong and it's gonna boom Shakalaka
your ass so you should leap the hell out
of the way this makes the shotgun a
pretty weak choice for Vanguard
activities especially given the
excellent critical damage that the
sniper rifle can deal to the big bads oh
damn look at them digits it's not a
rifle all good the fusion rifle is also
a solid bet for Vanguard Ori because it
excels at knocking out shields so you
can headshot et with your hero Canada
plus it's good to keep a few fusions of
varying damage types in your inventory
in case there's a modify
one of your big kid strikes when you
bring special weapons into the crucible
though it's a different story now you
have entered the house of the shotgun
and whether you equip one or not you
better believe an invisible hunter is
crouched somewhere waiting to blast your
boots off or about to Sprint's around a
corner or powerslide towards you then
pop up with the old blasting staff or
was it stab and blast either way if you
see someone running towards you and not
firing you'd better get your shotty
ready or backpedal fast because you're
in one shot country now space cowboy the
fusion rifle is equally one-shot capable
but the tell-tale charge sound sets
everybody's spider sense of tingling so
don't miss winging a guardian just makes
them really angry so be sure to finish
the job quickly by switching to your
primary weapon and a sniper well that
all depends on how good you are at
lining up a shot sometimes it's easy
like when you find a stationary target
or camp the heavy ammo spawn and
sometimes it's well sometimes you just
get your bell rung and that just leaves
two more weapon types coverage of which
I shall now pass off to the gun show
Repertory Theater the rocket launcher
and the machine gun a prologue to heavy
weapons both alike in dignity in fair
destiny where we lay our scene from
devastating blasts to fail rapidity wear
purple ammo
Renne purple gear unseen from forth the
fatal barrel towards crucible foes a
pair of fast fired rockets do Glide
whose multi-chambered spawn every
Guardian knows Daath brings swift end to
their enemies ride the fearful barrage
of a death charged spray and the
continuance of its deadly stream which
but magazines end nought could delay
unleashes a kill streak that buoys the
team and if for your allies to gather
you wait all shall get ammo so both meet
their fate and seen the guns of destiny
all wrapped up in a fancy little package
with a Shakespearean ribbon on top
you're welcome if you've got any tips of
your own to share stories about how
awesome the hand cannon is or requests
for fellow gun show viewers
join your fire teams chime in in the
comments below until next time be brave
become legend and never don't not stop
dancing
[Music]